so far
nearly 70 million people have contracted
the coronavirus around the world
more than 1.5 million people have died
from covet 19.
millions of others have been
hospitalized but there are also
many cases where patients only develop
mild symptoms that only last for a few
weeks or
show no symptoms at all and then there's
lung covid
that's when patients still experience
symptoms
months after a coveted infection there's
still a lot that researchers don't
understand about the novel coronavirus
and the same goes for long covid we do
know that
thousands of people say they've been
struggling with longer-term
symptoms some estimates say about 10
percent of covid19 patients
deal with lasting complications they may
include
breathlessness joint pain and fatigue
i remember one day i was lying in bed as
i
did the whole time and there was a glass
of water on my bedside table
and i was really really thirsty and i
did not have the energy to lift my arm
to get that glass of water
till two o'clock in the afternoon
because it was
too much effort i just couldn't
contemplate picking up a glass of water
even though i was really thirsty
patients are left in pain or unable to
breathe properly
simple day-to-day tasks become massive
challenges
and yet long covid is not yet recognized
as a disease
in many places i think one of the very
big problems that
these people face is that they need
recognition
they need a diagnosis they need a
healthcare pathway
and we're a bit of a long way off from
that still
so what exactly is long covid and how is
it different from covid19
it can be hard to distinguish between
the two in the first place
experts talk about long covid when
significant symptoms are still
noticeable
8 to 12 weeks after infection the
lasting effects can differ significantly
from person to person
adding to confusion for patients claire
hastie
founded a support group for people
suffering from long covid
after she found herself struggling long
after contracting covet 19
in march i've been very lucky that
unlike
lots of people in our support group my
doctor believed me from the beginning
a lot of people were told it was all in
their heads that it was anxiety related
to lockdown and goodness knows what
that were causing these incredibly
debilitating symptoms
but unfortunately my doctor and those
i've seen at the hospital don't know
what to do with me
scientists trying to get a better
picture of long covid have divided
complications into two main categories
there are respiratory symptoms together
with fatigue
and headaches and then there are
multi-system symptoms
that affect several parts of the body
like the heart
the brain and the gut these symptoms can
be especially puzzling for patients and
difficult to cope with
here's a closer look at what
long-covered sufferers say
they experience
initial data suggests that almost all
people who have long covid
experience fatigue in many cases it goes
beyond just feeling lethargic
it may mean feeling too weak to perform
even
simple day-to-day tasks i was unable to
get out of bed
for several weeks the fatigue was so
debilitating i could barely lift my head
off the pillow
i could shuffle to the toilet and that
was it
claire used to cycle 13 miles a day for
her work commute
now she can't walk for more than a few
meters
and needs a wheelchair whenever she
wants to leave the house
while most patients say they experienced
continuous fatigue
those suffering from headaches say the
pain comes
and goes many people in the neurology
and neuroimmunology space are start
starting to think about
mechanism and doing mri studies
and i think the answers that are
emerging is that there will be
um you know functional imaging
correlates of these symptoms
where you can see inflammatory events
and perhaps begin to work out what's
going on
a temporary loss of smell known as
anesmia is another symptom reported by
people with long covid
this is not true only for those who
contracted the novel coronavirus
a number of viral infections can cause
people to lose their ability to smell
for some time so these kind of things
are definitely
way up on the list um and
quite bizarre things um you know so um
people describing very specific um
smells that torment them
um one that i've heard moderately
frequently is
a kind of concern about smells of
burning toast so the fact
that um in osmium the effects and smell
and loss of smell
are so profound here really makes you
think
that the virus must be doing some damage
or some inflammatory damage
in the olfactory receptors or factory
centers
but you know early days for discovering
that
these include cough chest pain and
difficulty in breathing i went to
accident in emergency
five times over the first two or three
months
but my oxygen levels were never low
enough to be admitted
and so even though there were times when
i was practically crawling through the
door i mean i remember having to sit on
the pavement outside because i couldn't
i just thought i was going to pass out
but they said oh your oxygen levels are
fine go home so i was
i was sent home other common symptoms of
long covid
include a fast heartbeat joint pain
and a loss of taste patients have also
reported experiencing
so-called brain fog they find it hard to
think
clearly or focus and they feel confused
or disorganized sometimes effects of
long covet are all but
undetectable to the patients themselves
and they may be
unaware of the damage that's been done
to their bodies for example
involving internal organs we found that
if we use very sensitive imaging so this
is with
cardiac magnetic resonance we can see
inflammation of the heart muscle in a
huge proportion of patients now this
is a few months from the acute infection
meaning people
would consider themselves being
recovered and yet
we have seen involvement of the heart
muscle
according to initial data a number of
factors could affect how long patients
suffer from symptoms
linked to covet 19.
research suggests that people over the
age of 70 are twice as likely to develop
long covid than those between 18 and 49
years old
data also suggests that in the younger
age bracket
gender determines who's more likely to
develop long covid
the risk surprisingly has been reported
to be higher for younger women
than younger men somewhere between 35
to 45 55 who
have been fit and well before who may
have had
actually very mild acute infection but
all of the sudden
they develop this shortness of breath
tachycardia
meaning heart rate is very fast so they
are nearly inner heart failure
in in in in a standstill
and uh they are just not the same
and for instance the pumping function of
the heart would be still very preserved
but they cannot increase their
exercise capacity tolerance they are
simply out of breath
just sitting in a check
experts say the severity of a patient's
original case of covet 19
often says little about how they might
experience
long-covered symptoms whether you get it
or not doesn't even seem to correlate
very well with how severely
you had the acute infection because if
it was simply to do with how hard you'd
been hit by the virus
you'd imagine that the people who'd
perhaps been hospitalized had a high
viral load
had a very um explicit disease would be
most at risk for this
but that's not really the case however
the first week of covid
can be an indicator for whether a
patient develops long covet or not
those who show a large number of
different symptoms in the first week
are at a higher risk of long covet
researchers insist it's still too early
to draw
firm conclusions from this data but
tracking patients
early symptoms is seen as important
you know this is a story that we're
narrating in real time
and we don't know how long it's going to
go on for how it's going to end
so we don't know even if
this new disease that we're talking
about is um
a six month story a six year story or a
lifelong story
but whatever it is um it would be really
helpful if you could spot it earlier and
do
something to prevent it
researchers found that people with
asthma were more likely to develop
long-covid
studies into these risk factors and
long-covered complications as a whole
are ongoing we do need a year or two
to then be sure what is actually the
true
long-term effect of it so absolutely we
do not have this data
everything about this virus whenever we
thought we were confident
and had it sorted you remember at the
beginning people used to tell it's a bit
like flu will squeak it like flu
every time or you know you can see
what's its nearest neighbor
are the common cold viruses were people
treated as a neighbor of the common cold
and every time we had assumptions um we
were found to be wildly wrong
and had to rewrite the textbook and so
it goes on
for the time being experts are hoping to
draw parallels from similar diseases to
be able to deal with patients symptoms
however the problem comes when a patient
shows
different symptoms at different times
in most countries our medicine is very
clearly stratified
into specialties and the cardiologist
rarely speaks to the hematologist and
the hematologist
rarely speaks to the respiratory
physician and so it goes on and on and
on and you're either in one pathway or
the other
and most of them aren't very good at
speaking to each other so where on earth
you go if you're a patient who in
january feels breathless
in february feels you've got heart pain
and then march feels you've got joint
pain
and there is no pathway for you um so
i think you know we're all obligated to
build that pathway
the lack of a clear diagnosis moved
claire hasty to launch the long covet
support group on facebook
it now has more than 30 000 members
she's calling for governments to include
people like her
in the official covet statistics not
just those who have died or who have
been hospitalized
she also wants health experts to include
sufferers of long covid in policy making
and to take them seriously
we want to use the terminal covered we
think it's suitably
open and doesn't prejudge i think
there's sometimes
reference to post covid syndrome
and language like that and we think that
that makes assumptions that we don't
think research has
given us the answers to yet we don't
feel post anything
and so we feel very strongly we want to
use that name
we feel very strongly that the patient
has to be at the center of anything
nothing about us without us is the
principle that we're working with